hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i wanted to share five
things that in 2022 if you want to be a
millionaire you have to give up you have
to stop doing immediately and uh those
five things you might want to take a
notepad and pen and write these down
because this is super important i've
been in business now for 13 years and
i've made a lot of money in business and
i have
had to give up a lot of things in order
to become successful i mean right now i
live in a really nice house i have a
nice car i live in a beautiful part of
the world i've got a great family i've
got a great business and um
in order to have those things you need
to give up other things this is just
basic
business 101. so what are those five
things well you probably think i'm going
to say things like netflix
sleeping eight hours a day you know long
lines maybe you think i want to say
holidays uh social media get off social
media but actually i'm not gonna say
anything any of those types of things in
fact i actually believe that social
media is a really important tool for
your business i believe that lying in
and having eight hours of sleep a night
is actually really important guess what
i'm a millionaire and i sleep around
about eight hours every single night and
i think it's healthy um
holidays taking holidays it's a good
thing in fact i come up with most of my
i come up with most of my um business
ideas and concepts while i'm actually
away on holiday so i see a lot of videos
people saying you know work harder and
uh sleep less get up earlier 5am club
stop watching netflix i love watching
netflix it's great sometimes before you
go to bed you just need to just take
your mind off of business and and enjoy
something and watch our pleasant movie
with the missus and then have a good
night eight hours sleep that's healthy
that's good um so i'm not going to talk
about any of those things i think a lot
of people share things that they just
heard someone else say or read in a book
but these are the five things you
actually do need to give up in 2022 if
you want to be successful first thing is
excuses
excuses justifications if you're
thinking oh the reason that person's
successful is only because
they made it on love island but i didn't
make it on love island do you know what
that's called that's called a
justification as to why you're not
successful
excuses
you know oh you know actually it's
harder for me though because i didn't
have anybody help me i've got bad credit
so it's not as easy for me that's called
a justification that's called an excuse
so that is the very first thing in 2022
you have to just absolutely give up and
quit immediately so write that one down
next number two trading your time
for money what does that mean that means
and so many people i've heard that they
know this they've heard this they maybe
uh have read it in a book but actually
don't know exactly what it means listen
if you're trading your time for money
that simply means that you think that
you should be paid for your time as
opposed to your value if you want to be
a millionaire
okay or if you want to be a
multi-millionaire it's impossible to
make that happen
if you are trading your time for 10
pounds an hour
because if you're trading your time for
10 pounds an hour you're gonna have to
work
so many hours to become a
multi-millionaire that actually
your life ain't long enough
right so what you need to do is you need
to actually make your um
make your time more valuable but not
only that but stop charging people for
your time and start charging people for
your value no that's number two number
three what do you need to get rid of
what do you need to give up you need to
give up bad news
you know most people are addicted to bad
news in fact if you watch the news six
o'clock news 10 o'clock news
it's not the news it's the bad news
right it's just bad news why is it bad
news because that's what most people
want to hear and believe it or not the
news is just an entity a form of
entertainment pretty much and the news
wants to get clicks and eyeballs
because that's how they get their
sponsorships and their and their
viewings and their ratings and they know
that most people want bad news most
people are addicted to bad news you've
got to stop that
you've got to give that up you want to
be a multi-millionaire instead of um
instead of being attracted to bad news
you need to give that up all the gossip
who's doing badly oh my goodness did
that person just go bankrupt oh forget
it
run away from it
give it up become addicted to good news
just have to give up bad news negative
stories
unsubscribe
number four
the thing you need to give up is taking
advice from the wrong people
it's i find it really crazy how people
take advice from people who aren't
successful themselves it's like
if you want to become
an athlete and you want to get a
six-pack and you want to get ripped and
get super slim guess what
shouldn't take advice from me
right why because i haven't got a
six-pack i'm not super slim that's just
called common sense if i started telling
people going around saying to people
here's how you can get a six-pack here's
how you can lose weight here's how you
can be really slim here's how you can
run
a marathon and i've not done it myself
people would be like i'm not really
interested in your advice
yeah i find it crazy how many people
take advice financial advice
from people who are broke
from their mama from their school
teachers from their friends down the pub
they're taking advice about what should
i do my next move should i start a
business what should i call my business
um you shouldn't even be having those
conversations with those people because
they haven't done it themselves you
shouldn't be watching the videos of
people that are talking about how to
make more money when actually they
haven't done it yourself and i think one
of the biggest things that you need to
give up in 2022
is taking advice from simply the wrong
people and then number five
fifth thing you need to give up in 2022
to be a millionaire is you need to give
up completely give up fear
give up fear of failure most people
think that in order to succeed in life
or in business you've got to understand
this magical concept and how you can do
it first time and you can bang and be
successful but let me tell you something
in order to be a millionaire you are
going to have to fail
fail
failure and success are not two
different things in fact you have to
fail in order to succeed write this down
write this down failure is the stepping
stone to success
that's really interesting so in 2022 any
uh any fear that you've got of failing
just forget it
just think you know what actually let me
embrace it let me fail forward as i
think john maxwell famously said so
those are the things to give up
people's opinions listening to the wrong
people's opinions
fear of failure fear in general your
mind's job is to try and protect you
forget it you want to be super
successful you have to step out
fearlessly um
and and
and and listen sleep in man have a lion
take a holiday
watch netflix it's all good but those
last five things i said get rid of them
give them up if you want to succeed
2022. really hope you win in 2022. i'll
see you guys soon